like people protect the genders equally
I I do I do see what the problem with
men but
um in terms of how they're treated in
society but a lot of it are dare to say
that the misandry is almost a bit of a
pea pie like if you ask someone who's 50
plus about this they ain't got a clue
what you're talking about but they've
for the last 50 years seen women go
through this this and this and they're
probably like well of course what did
women really go through can I just ask
you that this okay what do you mean what
do we go through
what do you what do you mean what what
have we gone through I don't know it's a
question you said women have gone
through just do you think women are
oppressed no no no oh okay so that's
just that that's just straight off a
completely different opinion and if you
think they are you would have to explain
how they are yeah yeah what do you mean
explain how women are oppressed
how how do you think they're not no no
you're answering a question with a
question because like history history
okay if we go back to our diet I don't
know how old you are but that if we look
back to our Nan 25 25 so like my nan if
I go back to that far she didn't have
her own bank account until her 70s till
she till 1970s so she was 60 and how all
of this thought in terms of voting work
Child Care order that I don't understand
how you can step back and say no women
have got it all right no but you what
you've done there was conflict to time
time like you were saying 1970s yeah
yeah so in the 1970s that may have
happened but we're far from now but yeah
we might we're 50 years removed from
that but we're asking you today are
women oppressed they may have been
oppressed
you women actually weren't oppressed
historically uh I like because even
because I mean a common thing that I
hear women say is like the vote but the
thing is like the only reason we
couldn't vote was because we couldn't be
drafted and so and so like women
historically never had to fight in Wars
we were generally protected where men
were the ones that were sent to war and
had to die in order to build societies
was actually actually over the last 500
years women are more likely to wage Wars
than men when women were in positions of
power they're more likely to wage war
um so you could argue that like there
were more men in positions of power
throughout history that's that's true
but the thing is you have to think about
it from a historical context most women
didn't want to be in those roles because
they were very dangerous and people
would die like how many times were
Presidents assassinated et cetera Etc do
you think that that narrative that you
that you're spewing right now has been
quote unquote like we said ingrained
within you
um
I don't think it was ingrained at all I
think it's grown up and being sporty and
and not being taken seriously as the
boys it's it's being harassed on the
tube it's being touched inappropriately
it's been great it's seen people go
through that it's it's harassed on the
tube I I have if you've been through
that it's an unfortunate thing right
um but if you like at the get into the
conversation you you use the analogy of
a shark yeah and you said you wouldn't
go to Australia and swim anyway there's
been a shark so are you now saying that
you wouldn't go anywhere where there's a
man no because I I can't live like that
can I that's not that's not that's you
know that car no I don't drive okay
are you saying that men or you see men
as like Predators generally yeah right
you don't think that that mindset was
forced upon you you think that's like
just I mean that's personal experience
personal experience 100 I I don't know
how you think that's missandras uh a
little bit I'd imagine it is but again I
think if you was to sit down and talk
and the thing is with women I think the
more experience you've got you probably
have got more of that mindset but at the
same time because certain things have
made you have their mindset you're
always discounted because it's always
it's coming from a certain place like
I'm not silly if something happened to
me and it only happened to me then I
wouldn't have this opinion but when you
see it and when you hear it and then
when you see it and then when you hear
it and then it's in the media and then
it's the mums that you talk to on the
bench and the women at the school and
then you're seeing yeah
I don't know if like but some stories
all the time yeah but I'm not I'm not
I'm not believing someone that I've just
met do you know I'm not someone's not
coming up
but again these are people that I see on
a frequent basis at the park and at the
school I see their setup so this is the
thing I'm not saying that these things
don't happen I'm saying I think that
when you when you speak the way you're
speaking you said yeah you see men as
Predators I think that's a very
dangerous mindset to have in in this
Society because what it is is that you
are black you are blanketing all men I'm
not as pretty I said to you do you see
men as Predators yeah you said yes so so
I'm saying that that means potentially
there's four predators in this room
right yeah because there's four men in
this room
and if that's the way you've walked in
with that kind of mindset you don't
think that's dangerous you don't think
that's ingrained you don't think that's
inbuilt you don't think you'll pass that
down onto Generations I I think I've
come in here and I've never thought that
I was in danger because of the setup but
if I passed you for a man walking down
an Alleyway I would have a different
opinion
do you walk down Alleyways often well
there's free to get onto the estate I
live I've got no choice
it sounds like you're and I don't know
your left you know I mean I'm not trying
to judge you but it sounds like you're
living trauma no no no it's it's because
I had that eye conductor said to you if
you can have too many things happen to
you and they're isolated they're not
fair enough but if you've been through
that and you see other people going
through that and surely the best person
to listen to is someone like me that's
got the experience yeah I don't know you
know because I kind of think um like
have you noticed a lot of feminists that
are like very traumatized yeah and and
when you listen to what what they're
traumatized by it seems to be like
everyday occasions they'll be like oh
someone flashed me and I was I was
searching what does that say about
minlin no it just says that you're
fragile and you can't handle basically
do you think being flashed is acceptable
but
it's not yes not acceptable but what
physically happens to you like wow do
you not think that's intimidating I
remember a Story come on I get flashed
sometimes I got flashed in Nigeria am I
in therapy someone showed me her tits
and likes her party I didn't even ask
I'm still traumatized
Society needs to change
you've kind of like we promote this idea
of really fragile people who just like
do you know what could I I'm gonna
disagree with you just for the simple
fact I think being flushed is it's not
it's not appropriate I mean at the end
of the day that person or that
individual has gone the issue that he
needs to sort out and he needs to be
addressed personally but I don't think
that should be like it said blanketed
and covered with all men in an aspect of
all men are capable of doing that
therefore I'm not going to go to certain
places walk down certain alleys yes have
your wits about you and have that and
like you know Sarah said it's it's
almost like um
certainly situations have traumatized
you
and therefore you're not thinking
positively
or optimistically on other situations
it's just more narrow-minded
you need to look into why every day such
situations can traumatize you to that
level where you take on the mantle of
like the noble victim
um consider your mom your grandparents
the kind of stuff they dealt with do you
think do you think they would be
traumatized by the similar kind of
things no 100 I don't know how any woman
in this Society isn't to a certain
extent traumatized or doesn't know
someone that's been essayed or graped I
I don't have a choice like I've had
creepy I've had creepy things happen to
him I'm not gonna go but but it's a
choice whether to let yourself be
traumatized yeah that's a choice yeah
that's a choice if you let it affect you
for years to come that's a choice it's
not a choice but you're asking me my
opinion I didn't walk in here and I went
rude to you though because you're men
because I know that I I'm not saying
that like it's a badger because that's
what I'm saying
I'm not rude to any man because they're
a man at all but the way you just said
that is like we should be like on a
great
I weren't going to come in here and be
rude to you because you're a man that's
what I meant I'm not sure I'm not no no
I'm not rude to anyone find me a man
that I've been rude to and I'll swallow
I just said something yeah
as I'm I'm only 20 years of age at
obviously but I don't I haven't
experienced a lot but I've heard things
and seen things and everything and I
don't feel like I have hatred for men
out there like
I believe it all comes from trauma every
woman has their trauma and their reasons
why they hate men or come across as they
dislike men and can't stand a man do you
know what I mean but I feel like
I have I don't know what it is but I
feel like I have a soft spot for men and
that's why I don't hate them do you go I
mean like you have to be sexual
no
I wouldn't say that you're not
heterosexual no you're a lesbian no no
straight yeah yeah sorry sorry sorry
sorry okay yeah yeah sorry yeah I mean
like so you are straight yeah I'm
straight okay yeah and I don't see men
doing the same thing to women like I
know men that have experienced sex so
yeah yeah and I know that have been in
domestic violence situations and they
don't look at women as predators do you
I mean that's what I mean yeah but it's
not I don't think it's a daily
occurrence as it is for us why do you
not think that though isn't that an
assumption I think it's good because
considering if you were to say it's a
daily occurrence I know these women that
have had this experience were supposed
to take your opinion and and what you've
heard as as fact but I just think you
can stand here and say I don't think it
happens as frequently to men not being a
man not doesn't mean anything not being
in that space and that's like a valid
statement apparently I don't understand
of course but I think I could tell you
everything that's happened everything
that I've seen everything is and you
would still deny it yeah I'm a woman too
and I could say the opposite
foreign
happens I don't deny that they happen
right my I guess my issue is the
attitude that you have that spreading
that you say I'm not spending no but you
said men are men are predators you know
what I'm saying this is when you when
you say that you like I said you blank
it you blanket men like that and it's
like
um if men grow up this is what we talk
about missandry if men grow up in a
society where they are demonized right
from the get-go right just automatic a
demonize they haven't done anything you
you as a woman wouldn't like to be
demonized right it's just because you're
a woman
but the way in which you saw the video
and she wasn't demonized even when she
was but that one video I was gonna one
video but that that there's data to back
that up that men aren't taken seriously
as domestic violence and rape victims
and you just the thing is
oh I don't think it really happens the
thing is you said oh men are predators
you don't say no okay sorry so he just
asked me and I just went with yes over
no I like I explained to you I didn't
come up here and think he was Predator
if I saw you at night walking down an
Alleyway I would be scared
so you called him a predator you you
would be scared of me I 100 any man I
walked out I've lived uh so I've I've
had to walk a lot I don't drive I feel
like I'm a nice kind of guy I don't know
that though do I I don't know you I
would feel the same way
I feel like you're you're feeling
entitled to feeling to safety and the
thing is like men don't feel safe
walking alone at night either but aren't
they meant to protect us
alone if you're walking alone at night I
would argue that women are more likely
to be protected than if another guy is
attacked 100 yeah because if if Sarah
gets punched by some other dude like no
one's coming to see it but it's a man
punching I'll [ __ ] him up man
but it's a man punching you so it could
be I mean look at the video we just
wanted to be innocent it could be
innocent it could be the people have
done this experiment so many so many
times yeah it's very true you could look
up 10 videos about the same exact
experiment with the same exact result
men don't particularly type men
seriously so that's where I find the
problem if I went on not just finish if
I went on Tick Tock and saw a video of a
30 year old teacher that had raped a 13
year old sorry sorry the the comments
are from men saying oh that's my Teenage
Dream he would have loved that don't
tell me blah blah blah it's all men
saying it's men saying that yeah yeah
but the thing is there are some men
saying that but you're acting as if
there's women
as often not as often but you're acting
as if most men are saying that no no
what I'm trying to say it's like not
saying the way in which you're blanket
in men right now makes absolutely no
sense it sounds like you're taking it
like I mean you as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we
possible